you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
a warning that arctic sea ice could be
melting up to twice as fast
as previously thought
racing to win and to save the planet
how sailors in ocean race europe are
helping to collect
vital data about the health of our seas
and the herd of elephants 300 miles from
home
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions now some parts of the arctic
could have no ice by 2040 according to
new research from scientists at
university college london
they found that parts of sea ice in the
region are thinning up to twice as fast
as previously thought and that could
have a big impact on the rate of global
warming
the likelihood of extreme weather events
and flooding
in coastal communities well julienne
strouver is professor of polar
observation and modeling at ucl and
joins me now
welcome to you tell us more then about
your findings just how
serious is the situation in the arctic
well i think what was so novel about the
work that we did is that we're really
trying to get a better handle on how
much the ice is thinning because we have
over four decades of observations about
how much of the arctic ocean is covered
by sea ice
but it's been a lot harder to measure
how thick that ice is
and while we have satellites in space at
the moment that can
give us some ideas of sea ice thickness
a key unknown has always been how much
snow is on top of the ice and so
assumptions have been made that the snow
depth is on the order of what was
measured back in the
you know 1970s 1980s at north pole
drifting stations
but we know that that's probably no
longer accurate in today's arctic
because for one the sea ice forms so
much later than it used to
and so it takes you don't have as much
time over which snow can accumulate on
the sea ice
and so on a different project we had
produced a
more temporally varying snow depth
product based on combining
atmospheric re-analyses with a new snow
model to
sort of simulate how much snow is on the
ice and when you put
that data product into the retrievals
for measuring sea ice thickness
we found that when we do that yeah the
sea ice is thinning much faster than we
expected
and it's not too surprising but it was
nice to be able to quantify that this
is indeed the case and what are the
ramifications for that
what does it mean for climate change
well i mean obviously we've always been
concerned about well how quickly is the
arctic ocean going to transform
to a seasonally ice free arctic ocean
and you know we look at our climate
model outputs and they all suggest
sometime by the middle of the century
but you know if the ice is thinning
faster than we think then it could even
happen a bit sooner than what the models
are forecasting and so i think
it definitely has implications for yeah
the timing of when we might start seeing
arctic ice free conditions
and of course the arctic does not act
alone in our climate system what happens
in the arctic
doesn't really stay in the arctic it can
have implications for the planet as a
whole and exactly
how that plays out of course is still
quite uncertain
julianne struver thanks very much indeed
thank you
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and new
analysis shows that electric
and hybrid cars have seen another boost
in sales this month
one in five of all cars sold in may in
the uk
were hybrid and sales of electric cars
have grown from 2224
to 11 769 in just
one year now that's an increase of more
than 500 percent
in the northeast electric car sales have
increased from four percent of the
market
to 11 the un
is launching its decade of restoration
campaign which hopes to use the next 10
years to halt the degradation of
ecosystems
and restore them to achieve global goals
the body has hosted a major event with
world leaders including the german
chancellor angela merkel
and pakistani prime minister imran khan
u.n secretary general antonio guterres
had this to say
the task is monumental we need to
replant and protect our forests
we need to clean up our rivers and seas
and we need to green our cities
accomplishing these things will not only
safeguard the planet's resources
it will create millions of new jobs by
2030 generate returns of over
7 trillion us dollars every year and
help eliminate poverty and hunger
russian president vladimir putin has
said that it's a myth
that russia isn't concerned about
climate change
and that melting permafrost and coastal
erosion were risks
speaking at an economic conference in
saint petersburg he also defended the
use of natural gas
claiming that it's clean and should be
used in the transition to cleaner energy
a tsunami that hit scotland over 8 000
years ago would have devastated coastal
towns and cities
if it happened today according to
researchers the sterega tsunami
was caused by glacial underwater
landslides along norway's continental
shelf
in the norwegian sea triggering a major
displacement of water
modelling shows the wave could have
traveled up to 30 kilometers inland
along the scottish coast a hoard of
elephants that have trekked more than
300 miles away from their home in
southwest china could have done so
because of a decline in food in their
natural forest habitat
the 15 wild elephants have now arrived
at the densely populated city of kunming
the capital of yunnan province along
their journey they've caused around a
million dollars of damage
now 20 people from thorac and basildon
in essex have formed a climate jury
they're aiming to influence development
in the area whilst
ensuring environmental and community
needs are met
the jury have put forward 32 proposals
aiming to create a prosperous and
low-carbon future
their suggestions include investment in
cleaner and affordable public transport
as well as schemes allowing employees
days off to restore
nature well to talk more about the
proposals builder and climate juror
danny pierce joins me now
hello to you first of all why did you
decide you wanted to get involved in a
climate jury
i'll be honest with you um i was just
sent a letter randomly um
saying i could be involved in it and um
i've put my opinions forward so
it was currently like they've been
locked down so i thought why not let's
just have a go
see what it's like and i'll be honest
with you i was quite pessimistic at
first and
i didn't think it'd be something i'd be
too interested in but
as the weeks were going on i found
myself getting deeper
and they got more interested into it and
um
i was actually like looking forward to
the meetings and when it ended i
actually felt like something had been
achieved
at the end of it well that's fantastic
so you feel it's been a useful process
tell us a little bit about some of the
ideas that you all came up with
any favorites um
i'll be honest with y'all um i think so
cycle routes
uh uh was like a big one that kept
coming up and um
where they're planning to change over
like new production of uh
make all vehicles electric like cars by
um
2030 there was a there was a big issue
about
like the charging of them vehicles in
certain areas
so that that was an interesting one and
uh i think that's one that
definitely needs to be sort of addressed
going forward
and do you think you'll take anything
away from it personally about
how you live your life and how you do
your work you're a builder aren't you
any any lessons from what you've learned
during the process
um with myself i'm a little bit
i'm a bit restricted but i know that
there ain't there ain't many options at
the moment for myself or any
affordability for um
an electric van but it'd be it would be
useful and i'd definitely consider it if
they brought in
um almost like a scrappage scheme
um for like to trade in older vans
to replace them with like more more um
greener vans
i'd be definitely saying that'll benefit
myself as a builder and i'm definitely
saying i'll be interested in
interesting stuff well danny pierce we
really appreciate your time thanks very
much indeed
no problem thank you for having me the
second leg of the ocean race
europe kicks off this weekend and
several of the teams taking part will be
doing
more than just racing some of the boats
are carrying scientific equipment on
board
to measure the impact of climate change
on the seas and the amount of
microplastics in the water
while the three-week race started in
l'oreal in france on the 29th of may
before heading to
qashqai in portugal where the teams are
now now they'll set off from there this
weekend
racing to alicante in spain
the race finishes with genova in italy
on the 19th of june
and the data collected at every stage
will be
provided to scientific organizations
studying and mapping the impact of the
climate crisis on our oceans
well joining me now from qashqai is
simon fisher navigator for the 11th hour
racing team
uh welcome to you so tell us first of
all about this scientific research
element of the race tell us more about
what you're doing yeah thanks very much
for
being on um yeah it's actually really
exciting um
we're we're doing this three race and uh
we're obviously you know competing to
win but
also a real pleasure and um
an honor to also contribute to the
science uh to science community while
we're racing around i've
been racing in these boats or in this in
this
offshore racing for a long time now so
now i'm sort of getting to the veteran
stage of my uh sailing series nice to be
able to give something back
as someone who's got a bit of a science
background it's really nice that we can
we can contribute to
the science community well yes i think i
i've read that you're a
chemistry graduate aren't you so that's
obviously been part of the appeal
but what exactly is the research looking
at i mean you're looking at the quality
of the water aren't you but
are you also studying marine mammals as
well
yeah so um we uh yeah we have an ocean
pack
i can send the camera a little and you
can see this uh big box of scientific
equipment and
that's constantly as we're racing that's
constantly pumping water through the
boat and uh
measuring uh dissolved carbon dioxide uh
sea temperature uh salinity so uh
sea water salinity which are all really
metrics for for
gauging uh you know climate change the
uh
the the ocean actually absorbs like 90
percent of the excess heat that we break
as uh
the human race and uh and and the ocean
is also
carbon sink but um obviously the more
carbon the ocean absorbs it
the ocean absorbs the the bigger effect
it has on on the ecosystems and marine
life so
uh it's also hugely variable so i think
the more we can do understand that and
provide data it is very very valuable
and uh yeah we also uh you know but also
the eyes and the ears for the scientists
out here
specifically with marine mammals we all
really like well i'd
love to see the sea life and it's a real
pleasure when we see dolphins whales
birds
and that stuff when we when we're racing
and i'm sure but uh
actually by writing that down noting
noting observations wearing them
the frequency and things like that we
can actually provide a really valuable
resource to
the science community well simon fisher
it sounds
extraordinary good luck with the science
and good luck with the race as well
thanks very much indeed
thank you thanks for having me on well
that's it for today's show
but you can get your climate fix over
the weekend with our podcast
and on this week's episode we're talking
climate influencers with love island
star er booker
and katya jones from strictly that's on
climatecast and it's available wherever
you normally get your podcast from
and on our weekly digital show we go
behind the scenes of our correspondent
siobhan robbins is filming
with the divers collecting discarded
fishing gear and turning it into ppe
in thailand that'll be available on sky
news social channels our app and website
from saturday morning thanks for
watching see you next week
you